back in the early 1980s John Warnock
founder of Adobe had invented postscript
he'd pioneered all their work of getting
a PostScript interpreter embedded into
laser printers he persuaded Steve Jobs
at the time to say when your new
Macintosh comes out we want it to be
almost a dual announcement at the same
time but they didn't quite make it the
Macintosh did come out first of all a
little nine inch one we've done videos
on but alongside it fairly shortly
afterwards was the Apple laser printer
John had got the killer app he thought
to show off the skills wonder of his
laser printer driving with PostScript
the output and that killer example was a
United States income tax form for
supplementary income so he programmed
this up in his PostScript language you
sent it down to the apple laserwriter
which was so fast you couldn't believe
it but it took a minute and a quarter to
image it and the wondrous jobs of course
said John I know how to protect but I
cannot hold them for one minute and a
quarter while we press the button and we
wait for it to come out the light of the
friendships go blink-blink-blink so john
being a very good computer scientist and
knowing all about his own language
PostScript said yeah what we've got to
do steve is remove all the procedures
just get them automatically removed and
unroll the loops and make sure that
every if statement that we know what
data goes into that if statement so we
know which way it's going to go through
the program so we're going to flatten
the program this is sometimes called
going to linearize it we're going to
bind in the data and say we want the
fastest route to the final visual effect
so that's what he did and the unrolled
version imaged in 20 seconds not a
minute and a quarter so it really did
work
we teach our students very carefully
good programming principles we teach
them to use if statements for loops
blocks structured programming oh and
above all else isn't it nice to have
stuff off into procedures or subroutines
whatever you want to call them and to
call them up with superval arguments
nice it's clean and nice and structure
and gets you very good grades in your
coursework under the hood you always
have to remember that there is a bit of
a penalty performance-wise to be paid
for doing all this if you just consider
the humble four loop for example every
time you go round that loop the compiler
is building in a checking mechanism at
the top saying you said start at one and
in steps of one go on until you get to
six and do it round the loop like that
and every time you go on that loop it
has to say what's my loop counter at the
mum - oh I'm on three now let me take a
look at how far I'm supposed to oh six
is oh it's three less than six yes it is
oh I think we'd better go round again
it's that I exaggerate but you know what
I'm getting at equally if you dive into
a procedure you call it up with
arguments do remember on what we've done
already that that causes stack frames to
be set up to propel your arguments to
that function and to post them into the
function and then when the functions
finish doing its job it has to clear
down that stack frame and if the
function is recursive there might be
zillions of stack frames be cleared out
it's all overhead but its overhead that
you're probably prepared to pay because
it helps you think about the problem and
do it neatly and elegantly but if you're
concerned with performers of your
program to the nth degree these
overheads can begin to tell and
sometimes to get the optimum and maximum
performance under specialist conditions
you might want to say rather than going
round this for loop six times and doing
pretty well exactly the same
I will write it out by hand six times
and forget the for-loop would that be
quicker Nasir is very often yes what I
thought I'd do in the true spirit of
computer file this little example that
we'll do now we want to print out six
computer file banners look at that
correct font and everything as you all
know it's called OCR a I'm afraid that
my printer is a bit deficient it's
knocked off the corner of the pointed
bracket but please forgive okay so how
do we do it just using offer per script
for loop well very briefly I'll go
through this with you more details
available on the specialist PostScript
video if you need it every PostScript
program has to start with percent
exclamation mark this says I am
PostScript from now on comments in both
script programs begin with percent in
column one so program for zoo computer
file banners define the variable n to be
six
here is the PostScript command called
select font which says what font you
want and get point size do you want to
do it at we're saying find the font
called OCR a and at point size thirty
make me a copy of that ready for use in
PostScript here PostScript is anything
backwards in reverse polish notation but
effectively it is very simple it's a for
loop so it's basically saying for
starting at one and in steps of 1 up to
n but we know n is six do the following
code inside these curly braces now the
next line is saying we want six computer
files and they should all be at ten
points in from the margin and they
should be a hundred points apart when
you look at this carefully I'm doing
them upwards not downwards now you see
what happens when you start printing out
stuff probably designed for us letter
onto a4 paper your ten point almost in
what is it 72 points an inch I tried to
do a one seventh of an inch indenting it
didn't work it's all to do with paper
sizes but anyway going up the page at
one hundred point increments which is
a bit more than an inch sixteen
instances of computer file or
beautifully printed out and there's the
end of your for loop and finally it has
as it were virtually image do this for
you
inside its own graphic memory if you
want it to show up on your screen or
ultimately an old piece of paper you say
show page now some PostScript
interpreters if it gets to end of file
in your hands head show page will put a
show page in for you there's the show
page here's the thing done not in a for
loop but writing out six separate calls
of the command to print out computer
file at thirty point where you might say
well you used things like show and move
to and show page and here on this copy
you're not no I'm trying to show you
something which will be of use to us
later on that post which enables you to
redefine operators and to abbreviate
their names if you want to so up at the
top here I say look define just the
letter S to be the operator show define
M to be the same as moved
now the word bind just means remember
I've done this definition and don't
permit any other redefinitions that
might mess things up don't let anybody
else or don't let even yourself making
mistakes try and change it again this is
binding solidly m to being moved to
select font I've abbreviated as SF show
pages SP and look the very first one is
there that's 10200 move to and there
then another then another
and finally SP which is the abbreviation
for show page but I didn't write it out
by hand
I got a transform program to do it for
me because it's alright doing six of
these with a bit of fancy abbreviation
definitions at the top but if it was ten
thousand times out I don't want to
replicate something ten thousand in an
editor or by hand
here's a transform script which will
leave therefore in the notes if you get
it working right as a comment with you
and say yeah wow it worked for me you
should go to work out how to use it and
I should say this is a much much much
simplified version of the unrolled
transform script that John Warnock used
back in 1984 to get his income tax form
which was far more complicated than six
computer files to print out in a
reasonable amount of time on the apple
laserwriter just one final comment what
John did and what this is echoing here
in this abbreviation so why am bothering
to abbreviate the answer is well if you
unroll the loops and replicate things
you're making files bigger and bigger
and bigger
lots more printing isn't there in the
fire and that's not necessarily a good
thing
can we keep file size down yes by doing
the breviary and that realization
made by John in 1984 was the very
earliest glimmerings of what we now know
has PDF this particular server has four
Titan X graphics cards in it a Titan X
is one of the foremost graphics cards
there are new generation 10 and video
graphics cards coming out in turn AMD
card